[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it looks like
there's a new cap in town with the
arrival of the Falcon and Winter Soldier
on Disney Plus right around the corner
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the new team-up TV show as well as
giving my thoughts and what could happen
in the plot there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything about the series then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into my breakdown of Falcon and
Winter Soldier okay so just a quick
catch-up on the events of the MCU the
last time we saw Bucky in Sam was at the
end of Avengers endgame when Steve
Rogers had revealed that he traveled
back in time to smash Peggy Carr like
you should smash the like button on this
video now being too old for this ish
Steve decided it was time to pass on the
mantle and in the close of the film he
handed over his symbolic shield to
Falcon passing the torch figuratively to
him at San Diego comic-con during the
Marvel phase 4 panel Kevin Feige
director of the company finally
confirmed that the Falcon and Winter
Soldier show will be dropping in autumn
2020 with filming due to star this
October behind the project is Malcolm
Spellman who worked on Empire as well as
Derek Kolstad who created John wick so
yes some big guns pun intended or
heading of the show and it could
potentially be an action-packed drama
reprising the roles are all the big
stars of the films such as Anthony
Mackie and Sebastian Stan Mackie is
reportedly already being sized up first
Captain America costume so the show will
likely finalize with him donning the
star spangled man's infamous uniform in
the comics both characters at some point
have carried the shield however there
could be some back and forth between the
two before the one who dons the mantle
is fully confirmed it does look like
Bucky will try and find some happiness
similar to Steve though and recently
when talking about the show Sebastian
Stan said I think it's time for Bucky to
go out there and have an identity
outside of the circumstances that we've
met him through he might do all kinds of
things he might even go on a date
I don't know scary world out there you
know
apps things like that I don't know why
so scanner apps I don't know what he's
gonna do I can't see him on an iPhone I
think it's gonna be a lot of dealing
with Anthony's character and Anthony
himself which is always another
character in addition to this Daniel
Bruhl recently posted pictures of
himself in baron zemo's balaclava with
the caption I simply wanted to say hello
to some old friends gentlemen I'll be
seeing you very soon so it looks like he
could become the main antagonist of the
show going forward however there are
also rumors that John Cena has been cast
as the US agent for those who don't know
us agent is a government-appointed
Captain America and if the rumors are
true then Cena will be going
head-to-head with Bucky and Falcon for
the mantle especially since they are
still outlaws and on the run after the
events of Civil War along with Zemo
Emily VanCamp Sharon Carr is returning
to and it looks like the series will
heavily play upon the set but Civil War
forming with many of the aspects of that
film being built upon here if I was to
predict what would happen I would say
that I think the show will send a
heavily around the government who still
see Bucky and Falcon as enemies of the
state and because Sam will have
announced that he is the new Captain
America the authorities will want to
silence this and send us a Jim after
them the sides will go toe-to-toe wild
Simo operates in the background
perhaps framing them for crimes similar
to how we did in civil war eventually US
agent will discover the truth and
together with Sam and Bucky will help
take down Zemo US agent may step down as
a government-appointed Captain America
which will then allow Falcon to
officially take on the position the fact
that the show is called Falcon and
Winter Soldier and not Captain America
and Winter Soldier cements this for me
and shows that many will not be
accepting of this new position this can
also be the reason that cap wasn't all
that public at the end of Avengers
endgame and was listed as dead in
spider-man far from home he will likely
still be hiding from the government even
in his old age due to the events of
Civil War and all seems to line up for
me mark Barnard in recently spoke on
this during his podcast Batman on Batman
and alongside Kevin Smith they discussed
how the crux of the show will center
around the government being unaccepting
of a Sam's position though he didn't
state how he had this information and
that's everything we know so far about
Falcon and Winter Soldier and obviously
I loved hear your thoughts on it and
you hope to see in the show when it's
released comment below and let me know
and if you enjoy this video then please
like it and if you want something else
to watch make sure you check out my
breakdown of the recently released
Avengers and get deleted scene which
would be linked at the end in it I break
down the scene and discuss why it was
cut so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if you want
to come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey
it's the best way to get in touch with
me and it's the perfect place to suggest
new videos and content so hopefully i'll
see you over there also just want to let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of avengers endgame on blu-ray to
one lucky winner and all you have to do
is like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the Falcon and Winter
Soldier TV show in the comment section
below the one will be chosen at random
on August the 10th and the blue arrow be
shipped up from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]